come on down to I buy use phones we just
got in this iPhone 5s or something it's
got a working as screen scratches you
can only see in daylight and a charging
cable that's only slightly browning and
we throw in this genuine Apple plastic
bag for just three hundred and fifty
dollars
nope I'm not some sleazy phone sales
woman but I do know a heck of a lot
about trying to sell your iPhone before
the new one comes out this week
I sold my iPhone 6 for five hundred
dollars and the iPhone 5s for three
hundred as people start to upgrade their
phones more frequently and carriers try
to get you to stay with them nearly
every carrier or retailer offer some
sort of sell your smart phone deal but
which one is actually the best place to
get the cold hard cash well it turns out
selling a used iPhone is actually a lot
like selling a used car you'll make a
lot more money if you sell directly to a
real person and avoid the middleman
completely in fact this is really the
best way to sell seriously if you know a
friend or someone in your office or
school who wants to buy a phone it could
be the easiest and most cost effective
way but if you don't have success the
old-school way your next best bet is to
find a buyer online eBay and Amazon
obviously have the largest marketplaces
and of course there's Craigslist though
be on guard for the occasional back
alley meetup instead
I sold my iPhone 6 on a smaller site
called swap accom they make it easy to
list set an optimal price and charge
only a $10 fee I was on an eBay charge
at least 8% and we're more confusing to
use plus someone on eBay tried to scam
me here's the huge trade off with that
option though while you get more cash
you have to send the phone to the buyer
ASAP so you run into this problem I
borrow your phone for like a month
sorry honey I gotta go
that's why I recommend trade insights to
almost everyone despite it yielding less
cold hard cash try both gazelle and next
worth to see which will offer you the
most for your phone if they quote you a
price you like you then have 30 days to
send in your phone with free shipping
once they get the phone you'll be paid
either via check or PayPal so what about
those carrier buyback programs proceed
with extreme caution most of them don't
offer you enough for the newer phones
and they just want to trap you into
getting another phone or more service
with the carrier no matter where you
decide to sell make sure you save all
your important data elsewhere first then
turn off Find My iPhone and then reset
the phone to factory settings you never
know whose hands the phone may land in
this just in an iPhone 5 with tons of
saved passwords will even throw in these
earbuds with just a little bit of your
wax